[Music]
so you think you're pretty good on that
bike huh
how fast can you go have you done any
cool
jumps that's cool i guess but
compared to what i'm going to show you
that stuff is
child's play we
took it upon ourselves to give your bike
a bit of an upgrade
better shocks a nice new bell and oh
i almost forgot it can travel at the
speed of light
what would you see while you're riding
and
how would you look to other people
and this is safe right
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you rode your bike at the speed of
light
they say that traveling at light speed
is just like riding a bike
once you do it you never forget how okay
they don't
actually say that but if you did manage
to pedal your way to light speed
it's an experience you won't soon forget
the speed of light is about 300 million
meters per second it's a speed goal that
may seem ambitious but
with the new bike we gave you you should
be able to get there
we do recommend wearing a helmet you
know
just in case as you pick up speed you're
going to notice a few changes
first you would experience time dilation
basically the faster something moves the
slower
it moves through time if you're biking
along at the speed of light
time would stand still for you
pretty cool right
i need a break light speed is way too
fast for me
but while i'm here i want to show you
something check it out it's called raid
shadow legends
you can use the links in the description
to download it on a bunch of different
platforms like mobile
or pc raid is an rpg turn-based game
where
you can assemble a team of champions
make them stronger and
start kicking major butt ever wanted to
beat up an ogre
a dragon this freaky looking thing
well then raid shadow legends is for you
i
also got a kick out of leveling up at
the tavern like they're all just hanging
out like
cheers but with fantasy warriors also
there's this new feature called tag team
arena tag arena is the next
level of competition pvp battles so
if you're like me and you love getting
rewards for demolishing your co-workers
virtually
you're gonna love tag arena go to the
video description
click on the special links and if you're
a new player you'll get
50 000 silver plus 50 gems
plus one energy refill plus one clan
boss key
plus five mystery shards plus one day xp
booster
plus one free champion hex weaver
it's all there waiting for you so what
are you waiting for
click on the links in the description
and let's go slay some monsters
but then things start to get
trippy you'd see something called
the doppler effect this would cause the
color of the objects around you to
become
distorted
as you get closer to objects they'll
turn blue
with light different colors show us
different energies and wavelengths
the higher the energy the smaller the
wavelength
you're seeing approaching objects turn
blue because their
wavelengths are being compressed
if you look back at the objects you've
passed
they'll start to turn red as their
wavelengths are stretching out
the further you go you would start to
see wavelengths
unseen by the human eye ultraviolet or
infrared wavelengths would be so
compressed that
you could actually see thermal radiation
enjoy the predator vision while you can
though it's not going to last
here's the thing the faster you move the
darker
everything behind you will be as their
photons will be
less able to reach your eyes it would be
like
biking through a big scary tunnel then
eventually
you would only see darkness
also now would be a good time to pump
the brakes if you bike for longer than
one second
you may end up halfway to mars it would
be an experience
to say the least but what would it look
like
to other people
well research from the university of
surrey might be able to help us out with
this one
okay so this is the bike before it
starts moving
clearly they spared no expense on visual
representation
next the bike picks up speed the light
scattered from the front wheel of the
bicycle will travel
a shorter distance than the light
scattered from the back wheel
the biker is traveling so fast that when
the light reaches the spectator's eyes
the bicycle will be much closer to them
than it was when the light was scattered
essentially it would almost look like a
long photo exposure in that
the bike becomes one long movement
the bicycle will be made up of a
patchwork of itself
at different times
that poor viewer will see both your face
and back
at the same time will it be a once in a
lifetime experience
sure will they need therapy
we think so
in other words it's a mess to look at in
fact
whoever watched this light speed bike
ride is
probably going to throw up talk about
whiplash
so could you burn some rubber and go
as fast as the speed of light
no sorry as of now
traveling at light speed is impossible
especially for commercial bicycles
but what if we invested in that
technology and
were able to leave the speed limit in
the dust
what if we had working warp drive
technology
well that's a story for another
what if
you